CHRIS BANES: Hi guys, and
welcome to this week's Office
Hours, with me, Chris Banes.
NICK BUTCHER: Hi, I'm
Nick Butcher.
CHRIS BANES: Rich Hyndman.
RICH HYNDMAN: We're frozen.
There we go.
I'm Rich Hyndman, from London.
CHRIS BANES: As usual, we're
talking about latest and
greatest in Android from the
past week, and answering
questions from the Moderator
and in the Hangout.
Should we say hello to the
guys in the Hangout?
Hi, Weibe.
WEIBE ELSINGA: Hi,
good evening.
RICH HYNDMAN: Who else
have we got?
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
RICH HYNDMAN: And Giuseppe.
Hey there, guys.
Thank you for joining
us today.
Thanks, Giuseppe.
As usual we won't be answering
those questions that are
asking about product releases,
road maps, future facing.
But we will be talking about
Android developer things.
I'm just opening up Moderator
here on my Nexus 10.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, should
we kick off with
some moderator questions?
RICH HYNDMAN: Look
at our matching
back covers this time.
Nick's the only one who
is outstanding.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: Because you can't
buy them in the UK?
That is a shame.
Apologies for missing last
week's Office Hours.
We were all traveling.
But we are back now.
We'll try and keep our
regular schedule.
CHRIS BANES: And you
have a question?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Let's start
with the first question.
How to read crash on a device
rotation when hello dialog is
opened on the screen with
spinner in it open as well?
Asked from Mike in Sydney.
RICH HYNDMAN: What
was the question?
You've got two answers
there already.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah,
you have--
he has confirmation change, and
the hello dialog is open
on the screen.
And a spinner is open
in it, as well.
And if he goes to spin,
he gets a crash.
CHRIS BANES: What's spinner?
He means progress dialog?
STEPHAN LINZNER: So let's
check his code snippet.
CHRIS BANES: We have
a code snippet?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah, he
posted a code snippet.
In general, if you have a
dialog, you should think about
maybe using a dialog
fragment, and not
using the hello dialog.
This would maybe solve
some of your issues.
And if you use the dialog, I'm
just wondering, are you using
the methods on the Android
life cycle to create the
dialog and let the system
manage it for you?
Or do you manage the
dialog on your own?
CHRIS BANES: It doesn't
say what the crash is.
So it could be many,
many things.
Best way to do it is probably
to handle it yourself in
unsaved incidents, in the
unsave and restore state
methods, called on
your activity.
Probably best to handle
it there yourself.
I haven't really got
anything else.
The crash could be
many things.
Without more information it's
hard to say what the
actual cause is.
OK, shall we move on?
Lucas in Brazil has asked
why has [INAUDIBLE]
not have a param of limit?
Is it best to put it
on as append query
parameter in the URI?
I'd look at the source for
[INAUDIBLE] earlier.
And the reason is that content
result of that query doesn't
have any limit param itself.
And [INAUDIBLE]
is basically a wrapper around
content result of the dot
query with [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the reason, really.
If you want to have limit
parameter, you have to do it
yourself as a char
string on URI.
So yeah, that's the question.
RICH HYNDMAN: Welcome to the
other people who have just
joined us in the
Hangout today.
Lucas and Brendan, good
to see you guys.
CHRIS BANES: Is that Lucas
whose question I just--
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Do we have any
questions from the Hangout?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
So I just asked that in
public on Google+.
But I wonder if you have
some specific tip.
As you probably heard, I'm
working on this custom adapter
view, two-way view.
And I'm now adding accessibility
support to it.
So it works in the same
fashion than list
view and grid view.
So in each layout pass, what
it does is it has to detach
all the existing views in order
to do it all the view
recycling stuff.
List view does the same thing.
In order to handle focus when we
do the re-layout, for input
focus there are public
APIs that make this
very simple to implement.
You have [INAUDIBLE].
Save that.
Recycle everything.
And then you restore the focus
wherever it was, if it makes
sense to do so.
But for accessibility focus,
which is something more recent
in the platform, as far as I
know, I couldn't find any
public API to do things like to
query the system on things
like, where's the accessibility
focus now.
And things like, do I have the
accessibility focus if my
children has it.
And if I do have, then I want to
know the accessibility node
info on it, or the host view for
the accessibility focus.
Do you guys know of any public
API to handle these things?
Because it seems that list view
and grid view, they are
only using private APIs that
makes it very convenient to do
these things.
CHRIS BANES: I know the support
library has a couple
of classes in there, which have
support versions of being
able to query accessibility
service, and also be able to
access video events.
I haven't played with it much
myself, so can't really say
definitively whether it's going
to help you or not.
But have a look.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Me neither.
Have a look at the Docs.
It's
ui/accessibility/services.html.
And it basically summarizes
the API there.
But I haven't worked
with it either.
So I use some of
the attributes.
But that's about it.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm kind of
assuming that the reason it's
not public yet is just that you
want it to mature a bit
before exposing it
to every one.
Because there are things that
look like very good candidates
for a public API in
the private API.
There are things like request
accessibility focus on the
view class.
So this thing would be very
convenient if you're dealing
with things like
view recycling,
and stuff like that.
And also things like, you can
query the host view holding
the accessibility focus
at any point.
But that's using very
private stuff.
CHRIS BANES: Arey they public
methods with a hidden
annotation?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So this is why I'm assuming it's
just cooking a bit more
before exposing.
STEPHAN LINZNER: I think
you're right.
We have to be very careful
what you put out there.
MALE SPEAKER: I can
understand that.
It's just that for now,
pretty much--
the reason I'm asking is also
because it seems that the
whole adaptive view framework
is not really meant to be
extended at all.
I have to replicate a lot of
stuff that is in the parent
classes a lot of times.
And it's really inconvenient.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm looking at the
support library, as Chris
says, has got some accessibility
delegate methods
in there, and sending and
receiving of accessibility
events, as well.
I hadn't looked at it myself.
So what happens at the moment
if you put the device into
accessibility mode?
Does your list swipe when
you use two fingers?
MALE SPEAKER: I implemented the
whole accessibility action
bits, which is fine.
This is all done.
This is all working fine.
The specific problem I'm talking
about is when you
scroll and you recycle views,
you're going to lose the
accessibility focus if one
of the children had it.
It will pretty much reset the
accessibility focus to nowhere
every time you scroll.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you put that on
Stack Overflow and give us
a link as well, find some
more details on it.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
I linked the post on Google+ to
what I think is some of the
guys working on accessibility
on Android.
Hopefully they'll have a look.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'll look
for the post.
I can refer it to
them internally.
I know they're always
interested in actual
implementation of
accessibility.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm assuming
it's just
because it's recent API.
So it's trying things out
a bit in private first.
I can understand that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Good question.
Thank you very much.
CHRIS BANES: What have
we got next?
I'm going to make some notes.
STEPHAN LINZNER: The next
question is on how to achieve
drop shadow for views without
using a NinePatch.
Asked from David in Vienna.
I think you should really
think about the reason
why you need this.
Because the NinePatch is
probably the best you can do,
also, in terms of performance.
Chris suggested to disable the
hardware acceleration on the
view, and use a shadow layer.
CHRIS BANES: Who was it who--
David.
So you mentioned that it doesn't
work for hardware
acceleration.
That was the reason
why that was done.
You can set the layer
type back to
software, so software layer.
Disable hardware acceleration,
and it should work again.
But NinePatch is probably the
way I'd go, with a transparent
middle, so you're not getting
any overdraw.
If you really do need to drop
shadow, then those are the two
main options you've got.
Thanks for the question.
Is there a question?
RICH HYNDMAN: No, but the one
man Moderator machine, Andrew
Kelly, has pointed out that the
video stream may not be
working in the YouTube
player right now.
There we go.
We can ask him, as soon
as he joins in.
Maybe you can put it in the chat
window, if you've not got
a microphone, Andrew.
Did you get the YouTube
window working?
Showed up on three.
CHRIS BANES: We did ask another
question, actually.
RICH HYNDMAN: You've
got a question
for him in the Moderator?
CHRIS BANES: There's two.
He's asked, any thoughts on
why a Home screen shortcut
would remove when your apps
are graded and install
location is set to
internal only?
NICK BUTCHER: There's a good
blog post on our blog called
things that cannot change.
It sounds like you've
change one of them.
Basically, what normally happens
if you had to change
your package structure, if
you've moved your home
activity to a subfolder or
something like that, then
these things can't change.
Because that's the component
identified on that node.
The desktop shortcut
basically is a link
to a specific intent.
And so if you change
that, then the
shortcut will stop working.
What you can do is create an
activity alias at the old
location, which basically
will forward you
on to the new location.
So that's good practice if you
are going to do this kind of
refactoring.
So that you don't break
anyone's home screen shortcuts.
But if you look on the Android
Developers' blog-- it's
android-develope
rs.blogspot.com.
There's a post called "Things
That Can Not Change," by
Dianne Hackborn.
Check that out.
GIUSEPPE: Can I ask
a question?
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey, of course.
GIUSEPPE: I use an XML selector
to meet different
button state, and
source selector.
RICH HYNDMAN: Which
XML selector?
GIUSEPPE: Selector [INAUDIBLE]
XML.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK..
GIUSEPPE: When from the activity
I use the select
image resource, and then I call
the XML selector, the
system image resource taking
care about the memory,
[INAUDIBLE]
et cetera, or I have to take
care myself about the bitmaps?
RICH HYNDMAN: You're talking
about all the different image
states that you're going
to have on the button?
GIUSEPPE: No.
Sorry.
I will explain again.
I have an XML with selectors
inside, with
pushed, pressed, focused.
Each selection have
a different image.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
This is--
GIUSEPPE: The same image view,
I change the XML selector
using set image resource
at runtime.
On some specific device, I'm
experiencing out of memory.
I don't know if the set image
resource is taking care about
the restoring of the
old image or not.
CHRIS BANES: I'm
not 100% sure.
But I'm pretty sure when you
load the drawable it will load
all of its child drawables
at the same time.
You have a drawable which will
have x number of bitmaps based
on the status.
GIUSEPPE: Correct.
CHRIS BANES: So there
is no real way of--
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't think
there's any provided way of
you to recycle those images.
Have you done some tracing on
where the memory is going?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
It's like when I change the
resource the image that was
loading before didn't unload.
RICH HYNDMAN: Are you changing
the resource a lot?
It's supposed to be pretty
hefty, right?
GIUSEPPE: Yes, because this is
connected with a button that
is pressed many times
on the screen.
RICH HYNDMAN: And every
time you press it--
GIUSEPPE: Totally there are
four image in the XML.
And another four image
in another XML.
So using the set image resource,
I switch the two
different XML files.
RICH HYNDMAN: And when you
switch you can see memory
going up and up and up?
GIUSEPPE: Up, up, up.
NICK BUTCHER: A cleaner way
might be to, instead of
switching resource yourself, why
don't you define your own
custom states?
Then you can have different
drawables in your stateless
drawable reacting to your own
custom states, as well as the
Android states.
RICH HYNDMAN: Or you could
have two buttons.
CHRIS BANES: What platform
is this on?
What version?
GIUSEPPE: What version?
They go on 404 and 236.
CHRIS BANES: That's interesting,
because--
GIUSEPPE: And all the devices
that send the out of memory
report, I know that they are any
times signed like others.
Others device.
When in the panel you
have others device?
There are no specific names,
like Nexus or et cetera.
CHRIS BANES: It's interesting.
Because I would have thought
that the drawables are loaded
with input shareable.
So that if they aren't being
used, they'll get purged
straight away by the system.
But that was added in 3.0?
It's about 2.2, 2.3.
So honestly I don't
really know.
It sounds like a bit
of a [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: It's saying
nothing stated about you
having to clean it up.
And I don't think we provide any
methods for you to clean
it up yourself.
CHRIS BANES: You can
for the drawables.
GIUSEPPE: In the last
documentation--
RICH HYNDMAN: Giuseppe, gone?
Giuseppe?
CHRIS BANES: We've lost him.
He's gone, frozen.
RICH HYNDMAN: Interesting.
Oh, wait.
No, someone else.
GIUSEPPE: The set image drawable
or set image bitmap
don't work.
Because I need a different state
for the same image view.
RICH HYNDMAN: What
are you saying?
So you're using set image
resource instead?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: You could create
a stateless drawable and use
set image drawable.
Or you could define custom
states, just
use a single button.
Because I think it might be
doing this set repeatedly,
which is your problem.
GIUSEPPE: Do you mean to create
a custom state, so take
three on each change of the--
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
So if you're doing a play pause
button, you could have a
state saying playing, and that
could be a Boolean selector,
like true or false.
So when you do your stateless
drawable, the different states
you react to, one of those could
be playing, as well as
the Android underscore focused
underscore pressed,
and stuff like that.
So you could provide your
own states as well as
using custom states.
In fact, [? Lucas, ?]
I think one of your colleagues
on Firefox did a good blog
post about how to do this.
Do you happen to
know the blog?
I can't remember.
MALE SPEAKER: I can link
that on the chat.
NICK BUTCHER: That
would be awesome.
Yeah, about how to define
your states.
I saw that the other day.
Yeah, it sounds like an issue.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
It does sound like an issue.
Should be run the bug as well?
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
CHRIS BANES: Hello.
Who said that?
MALE SPEAKER: I was there
a couple of weeks ago.
I'm the one with the white
web view problems.
CHRIS BANES: Hi.
MALE SPEAKER: So you suggested
disabling the hardware
acceleration.
And I did that.
And it changed nothing.
RICH HYNDMAN: You disabled it
for the whole application?
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry?
RICH HYNDMAN: You disabled it
for the whole application?
MALE SPEAKER: I can't
understand you.
I'm sorry.
I'm not a native speaker.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Did you disable
hardware acceleration
for your whole application
in the manifest?
MALE SPEAKER: I did.
STEPHAN LINZNER: So not
only for the web view?
MALE SPEAKER: Not only
for the web view.
For the whole application.
STEPHAN LINZNER: And what
are you seeing?
NICK BUTCHER: Can you
restate the issue?
I can't remember.
Is the question in
the Moderator?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
It's one of the questions.
It's the one with the
Stack Overflow link.
CHRIS BANES: OK, yeah.
I put an answer in, saying it
sounds like HTML issue.
Have you tried running that web
page in the normal Chrome
App, or the browser app?
MALE SPEAKER: I tested
it with [INAUDIBLE]
validation.
And they lead to HTML.
I don't have Chrome
on my mobile phone
because it's too old.
But actually I didn't try
it with the browser.
The fact is that usually
it works.
It starts being white
after a while.
If I reboot to my phone, it
starts working again.
So I suspect it's something
else, not the
HTML, which is correct.
It's a simple table,
nothing fancy.
STEPHAN LINZNER: And
this happens
in the Android browser?
And you're not able
to test on Chrome?
MALE SPEAKER: No, I'm not
able to test on Chrome.
And it's happening
in a web view.
I didn't really test
on the browser.
It's strange.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Are you running
some JavaScript?
Or is it just markup?
MALE SPEAKER: I'm running
some JavaScript,
which I didn't write.
It's to render [INAUDIBLE].
And the strange thing
is that I only get
problems on Android 4.
On Android 2, no problems, no
one ever reports any problem.
On Android 4 I get
this problem.
RICH HYNDMAN: I remember.
That's why we thought
it might be hardware
acceleration related.
MALE SPEAKER: I use in CSS
rotations, not directly.
My JavaScript code can, because
I didn't write the
JavaScript code to render
[INAUDIBLE].
I just copied it from somewhere
on the internet.
I had fun with those.
I will investigate.
But no, it's not a problem
with CSS rotations.
Because my guide first page
has no CSS rotations.
RICH HYNDMAN: We might have
to skip that one.
I don't have an answer
for you.
It would require a bit of
debugging, and playing with
the HTML in the code.
I haven't heard of this problem
before with the web
views going blank.
We use them in a lot of
applications all the time.
And we see them in a lot
of applications.
And I've not seen them ever
just appearing blank.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
links are working.
That's the really
strange thing.
If I click on the link,
it takes me to
another white page.
But I have to push the back
button once more.
So the link is actually
working at first.
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't
know why that--
sorry.
Unless you're making
use of a feature--
STEPHAN LINZNER: With version
4, you might try out get a
phone which runs Chrome.
Because then you can have
the remote debugging.
You said you did not write
the JavaScript.
But it can still use remote
debugging to go through step
by step through JavaScript.
And you might find the point
where the problem starts.
I think we have no answer
for you right now.
MALE SPEAKER: I look into
this JavaScript code.
Because actually I
didn't write it.
So it might be a problem.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, let's shift.
Thanks for the question,
again.
Sorry we couldn't help you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: It sounds quite
specific to your application.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
RICH HYNDMAN: Have we got
any favorite questions
to follow up with?
NICK BUTCHER: There's a question
here from Andrew
Kelly about setting the window
background to null in its
theme to reduce overdraw.
And you ask is that
advised to do?
And you can do it.
But you have to be extremely
careful.
Basically, if you're setting the
window background to null,
you have to ensure that
everything you draw on screen
has a background on it.
If there's any component like--
we were talking about
this earlier-- like action bar
tabs, which have a null
background, a transparent
background, then you're going
to get unexpected behavior.
So while you can set the window
background to null if
you know what you're doing, I'd
advise you to actually use
the window background
as a base color.
And remove backgrounds
from things on top
of it if you can.
Another thing to be aware of is
that when you're launching
your activity for the first
time, in order to get a very
snappy performance to have the
app launch, Android does an
optimization where it will
actually take the background
color of your window and your
action bar, and animate those
opening, and then draw your
app on top of that, to get
this faster response time.
And it's an optimizational
trick.
So if you're setting a null
background in your theme, then
we won't be able to do that.
So you will get this slightly
worse behavior.
So for that reason, I advise you
to set a background color
in your window if you can, and
reduce the overdraw on top of
the background where you can.
By removing backgrounds on
the views within layout.
That's my advice.
STEPHAN LINZNER: There's another
question from Andrew
Kelly regarding window
soft input mode.
He basically has the problem
that there's some problem on
HTC devices.
And you're asking for advice
on what is the best way to
handle those issues with
manufacture, or having
problems on the different
devices.
I think there's no easy way, or
no best practice to do it.
What I did in the past, what I
was using a factory, I had
this one object.
And I was querying it.
And it would return me an
object, and it had methods on
that object.
In your case it will
be set window soft
input mode, or something.
So you could only create a
factory and use this one
object, and just call one
method on the object.
So if you have different
vendors, this is pretty handy.
But it's still only
a workaround.
There's really no solution for
these kinds of problems.
And they're hard to find
and hard to tackle.
But I would use a factory
to do it.
CHRIS BANES: One thing I have
got is try not to add checks
for vendor or models, or
anything like that.
Try and do it generically.
For this example, it's about
the keyboard being open.
So I'll give you an example
where you can set the flag to
have state visible on
the IME options.
And then in your resume or maybe
a bit later, check if
the keyboard is open.
If it's not, then force it open,
as you would on an HTC.
So try and keep it generic, and
not add any string checks,
or anything like that.
Because it's more possible.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Never do it.
Only do it if there's no
other way around it.
OK, do we have a question
in the Hangout?
MALE SPEAKER: I actually
got a question.
First of all, Stephan,
your t-shirt rocks.
STEPHAN LINZNER: I know.
MALE SPEAKER: I got a question
about a spinner.
Yesterday, for the first time, I
found myself having to use a
spinner, and finding out if I
selected something that has
already been selected.
What I figured out is that on
Item Selected on Item Selected
Listener doesn't get triggered
if you reselect an already
selected item.
I did solve it by making my own
spinner, and overriding
the set selection method.
But I'm just wondering if that's
the way to go, or if
you have some other advice
on how to achieve this.
CHRIS BANES: Why do
you need this?
Because for a spinner, the
selected item would be at the
top, anyway.
STEPHAN LINZNER: What's
your use case?
Do you want to refresh?
MALE SPEAKER: In our situation
I have some columns.
And I want to sort those columns
that are defined in
the spinner.
And if I select the same item
again, I want it to sort
ascending or descending,
whatever it was before.
STEPHAN LINZNER: I think it
works the way it should work.
Because obviously
in your case--
I think it's a UI problem.
You should maybe think about
adding a different button, or
a different spinner
to do the order.
Or rethink your interaction.
Because I think generally
it's a bad thing.
And I also would say it's not
behavior you would expect to
change the order, by clicking
again on the item.
That's just my side of things.
CHRIS BANES: One way you could
do this is use a standard
spinner, but in your
spinner listener--
your item selected listener--
after you've done your sort and
all that, you then call
[INAUDIBLE]
zero or minus 1, just so your
item isn't selected again.
So you reset the selection.
NICK BUTCHER: Is this going
to be an action
bar item for sorting?
MALE SPEAKER: At this
point in time it's
just a plain spinner.
NICK BUTCHER: You could look at
using a pop-up menu rather
than a spinner.
Then you have full
control over it.
That's a pretty common way of
presenting these options.
Like the overflow menu in the
action bar, the pop-up menu
will pop down from there.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: You're welcome.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers, guys.
With that, we are out of
time again for this
week's Office Hours.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Too enthusiastic
on the yes there.
But thanks all for joining us.
And I'll look for that post
on G+, [? Lucas. ?]
Good to have you hear today, and
everyone else who joined
us in the Hangout.
Thanks, very much.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GIUSEPPE: Bye bye.